all of us in the Ingram household were
like most Americans disappointed when
this afternoon SpaceX launch was
scrubbed due to storms in the area
Mission Control decided that weather
risk was too great to take the chance
so they rescheduled for Saturday
afternoon when they'll make a new set of
risk calculations before takeoff is
attempted again now this got me thinking
about risk assessments that we all make
every day decisions big and small that
have enormous consequences on our health
our well-being our inner sense of
Harmony our finances walking out of the
house every morning instantly exposes us
to risk stepping into a vehicle buying a
stock even ordering at a restaurant all
involve a certain level of risk but you
think about it if we never take risks we
never move beyond the status quo we
never innovate we never improve we never
learn we never grow now while the corona
virus is novel our approach to it like
our approach to every challenge also
includes risk letting citizens make
their own decisions determine their own
destinies well that's the hallmark of
our free society yet time and again the
left has moved to limit individual
choices on very personal decisions from
whether you can buy a firearm to whether
you can even educate your own children
at home to the type of car you drive to
your right to speak freely on social
media now other than pushing for the
right to abortion or or maybe marijuana
many liberals today have become very
liberal and their argument against your
exercising your own free will it's
always the same they claim that you're
putting yourself and others at risk and
then they use scare tactics and
sometimes skewed statistics to push
their agendas from gun control to
climate change and rather than passing
actual legislation they'll often do this
through emergency decrees or other
executive action
now indeed this has been the pattern of
blue state governors and radical mayor's
during kovat 19 they simply don't trust
their own citizens and at times they
seem to relish punishing them a
political rally like that where people
aren't wearing masks and they're in
close quarters and they're touching one
another I you know that s precisely what
makes this kind of a disease drag-out
that puts us in this situation where we
might have to actually think about
extending the state home orders and she
did extend the stay at home order now
also Andrew Cuomo like he needlessly
pushed for this complex plan called New
York forward it requires only seven
metrics to get to phase one of reopening
if you can believe it and this as the
city is literally and figuratively dying
mayor de Blasio still has no detailed
plan to reopen New York City restaurants
and bars
so we're gonna figure out how and when
we could reopen bars and restaurants how
much outdoors is going to play a crucial
role in that I think it is a very very
encouraging possibility to lean to the
outdoors but even with that we got a lot
to figure out in terms of social
distancing face coverings protocols and
what amount of capacity you could create
that would make it worthwhile now nine
weeks into this they still haven't like
thought this through
I trust any random restaurant tour to
make reopening decisions over that guy
any day I wouldn't trust him to drive an
ice cream truck for goodness sakes
and notice how none of the rules that
these power-crazed governor's our
mayor's forced on you ever apply to them
the latest fraud is New Mexico's
governor michelle lujan-grisham
here's what she's been up to well KRQE
news 13 has learned that in April when
she ordered non-essential businesses to
shut down and lecture to all New
Mexicans to stay home a non-essential
business opened up so she could buy
jewelry and have it delivered to her
again rules for thee but not for me now
of course she's defending her
hypocritical conduct so with a
spokesperson saying the store was never
opened and a good safe process was
followed Oh
the governor has of course in both her
personal and professional lives adhere
to all the public health measures the
state has enacted during the duration of
the pandemic sure she's on the short
list of Biden's potential VP picks by
the way now far away in Hawaii a state
with only I kid you not again one is too
many but only seventeen Cova deaths
Democrat governor David egg is that how
you pronounce it doesn't trust his own
people to manage their own kovat risks
he hasn't even finalized a plan to end
his stupid inter-island quarantines well
they're saying this earlier the Aloha
State is going to say Aloha as in
goodbye though to any hope of recovery
if it doesn't wake up soon
the angle of course isn't saying that
the coronavirus shouldn't be taken
seriously we take it very seriously the
human toll the economic toll of course
we passed a hundred thousand deaths it's
been heartbreaking
it's the enormity of it is it's
sometimes hard to even take in what we
are saying at the same time as those
states that have given more trust to
their own citizens are doing better than
the states who treat their citizens like
school children we believe that pastors
at the local church are gonna do I think
their best to balance their duty to God
with the duty they have to the safety of
their congregations and we believe that
local like high school football coaches
are gonna balance their duty to their
schools with the duty the their players
and preserving their health we believe
that local restaurant tours yes we'll
figure out how to best balance their
desire to stay profitable with their
duty to keep customers and workers as
safe as possible and look if they sleep
a slip off this is where the free market
comes in they'll either be sued they'll
go out of business or both but let's
face it some elected officials never
like the free market that much they
prefer to keep a lot of you deplorable
as locked down and afraid they want you
masked not just during this virus but
until the end of time because remember
there will always be another potential
virus lurking out there right around the
corner don't you want to protect others
what kind of monster are you if you
don't want a mat wear a mask forever now
they talk about unity in crisis while
they turn neighbor against neighbor
reporting on each other for violations
but the truth is they don't believe in
their own rules because if Virginia
governor Ralph Northam was really
convinced that wearing masks will save
lives he would have worn a mask at the
beach last weekend and if Illinois
governor JB Pritzker really thought the
lockdown measures were so great in his
state he wouldn't let his family travel
and risk their lives to go to risky
dangerous Florida and
and if Michigan's governor Gretchen
Whitmer really thought that traveling up
north was gonna put folks in jeopardy
there
her hubby wouldn't have traveled there
to take his boat out of storage but all
of these pro lockdown governors were
willing to take risks they deprive their
own citizens from taking but the risks
are being taken anyway what am I talking
about well investors today continued to
bet actual money on the great American
comeback think about it they're not
betting on more lockdowns they're
betting on reopening and recovery the
world is moving on you read it you feel
it you sense it now I understand the
medical establishment doesn't want us to
move on the media they certainly don't
want us to move on and liberals do not
want us to move on but we are we're
moving on we may not take you know and
have all of the talent of Elon Musk but
no one should deprive us of our own
rights to launch our own dreams raise
our own families build our own
businesses and worship God as we always
have and that's the angle